je vais appeler le dernier le dernier
amendement de cette série qui est
présenté par Monsieur Catena
merci monsieur le président
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chers collègues
chers collègues j'ai un rappel au
règlement
chers collègues
j'ai un rappel réglement que je vais
prendre qui est celui de Monsieur
Cazeneuve et puis je donnerai la parole
à l'orateur merci Monsieur la base de
quel article monsieur le député sur le
fondement de l'article 70 alinéen ce qui
se passe ce soir ne peut pas être passé
sous silence nous avons eu
[Applaudissements]
pendant des députés sont sortis de cette
hémicycle parce qu'ils n'ont pas gagné
au tirage au sort et quand l'un de leurs
collègues
qui a été condamné pour avoir frappé son
épouse prend la parole sur un amendement
vous restez stoïque pire que ça vous
l'applaudissez
on est c'est scandaleux c'est nous merci
monsieur le député
alors
j'ai un deuxième rappel réglant cher
collègue je vous le donnerai madame
également
cher collègue monsieur de legu c'est de
Leguy vous vous asseyez
chers collègues monsieur delogu c'est de
l'augu
alors on va se calmer immédiatement
deux rappels en règlement monsieur
Maillard puis madame Amiot nous allons
chacun les entendre s'il vous plaît
sur la base sur la sur la base en hiver
je
demande une suspension de séance 2
secondes
2 secondes j'entends c'est pas la peine
hurler j'entends j'ai entendu bon
on va faire les choses dans l'ordre
chers collègues nous allons faire les
choses dans l'ordre
alors
[Musique]
j'attends que vous vous taisiez
[Applaudissements]
j'arrive j'arrive j'arrive oui elle est
de droite vous avez raison monsieur le
Président c'est le président Marc en
jolie je suis sport pour 2 minutes
et nous allons reprendre nos débats
avant cela
j'ai donc et avant que je regarde s'il y
a des rappels règlements après mon
propos on verra j'ai donc noté qu'il y
avait eu des propos de nos collègues qui
avaient
permis on va dire une scène à une sorte
de tumulte on dirait une scène
tumulteuse je vais donc indiquer à notre
collègue de l'audio au titre de
l'article 71 2 un rappel à l'ordre sans
inscription procès-verbal de façon
pouvoir revenir dans le calme et pouvoir
reconnaître que ce propos a été tenu et
qu'il est inscrit au compte-rendu je
pense que ce cyclo la série de rappel au
règlement je l'espère et qu'on peut
reprendre non il y a quand même il y a
quand même deux rappels en règlement je
les prends dans l'ordre alors ce qui le
fait au groupe c'est monsieur
sainte-huile je vous écoute sur la base
de quel article
sur la base de l'article 70-1 comme
Monsieur Cazeneuve je veux dire ici avec
une certaine gravité mes chers collègues
que si jamais aucune explication ne
pourra justifier des violences faites
aux femmes que si jamais nous ne pouvons
accepter cela que mon propos n'est en
rien en solidarité avec les actes qui
ont été commis il n'y a pas ici dans
cette hémicycle un député ou une députée
légitime a considérer qu'il peut ici
entraver la démocratie vous avez
applaudit votre première ministre cet
après-midi qui vous a dit que c'était ni
attribual ni les procureurs respecter la
règle vous ne pouvez pas faire ça si
vous considérez si vous considérez que
c'est inacceptable parce que dans vos
valeurs et vos fondements
voilà on s'éloigne un peu du rappel au
règlement je vous remercie vous n'avez
plus la parole monsieur le député ce
député vous n'avez plus la parole on
s'éloigne du rappel au règlement et dans
un souci de calme je vais prendre le
second rappel au règlement de Madame
Ménard et puis nous reprendrons nos
débats enfin nous essaierons
merci monsieur le Président sur la base
de l'article 70 alinéa 1 également
nul dans cette assemblée ne pourra me
suspecter de sympathie particulière à
l'égard de Monsieur katmans néanmoins il
me semble important de rappeler qu'on ne
peut pas à longueur de journée ce
gargariser et donner des leçons de
démocratie de séparation des pouvoirs de
respect des règles de la juste de la
justice et de la liberté d'expression
qui sont des règles importantes dans
notre hémicycle et que nous devons tous
respecter on ne peut pas faire ça et ne
pas respecter
le Play principe de base de notre
justice monsieur cattenin ça a été
condamné je ne reviendrai pas sur sa
condamnation
aucune peine d'inégibilité je rappelle
aucune peine d'innigibilité n'a été
prononcée à l'égard de Monsieur katmans
c'est une décision de justice qui
s'applique et maintenant je pense qu'il
faut que la respections tous ici je vous
remercie
alors
voilà un bel hémicycle bien calme et la
parole est à l'orateur pour l'amendement
1908 monsieur catins
merci monsieur le président qui a dit
est-ce qu'il faut reculer l'âge légal
qui est aujourd'hui à 62 ans je ne le
crois pas tant qu'on a pas réglé le
problème du chômage de masse dans notre
pays franchement ce serait assez
hypocrite de décaler l'âge légal je veux
dire aujourd'hui quand on est peu
qualifié quand on vit dans une région
qui est en difficulté industrielle quand
on est soi-même en difficulté quand on a
eu une carrière fracturée bon courage
déjà pour arriver à 62 ans c'est ça la
réalité de notre pays alors on va dire
non maintenant il faut aller à 64 ans
vous savez déjà plus comment faire après
55 ans les gens vous disent les emplois
ne sont plus bons pour vous c'est ça la
réalité ces mots sont ceux d'Emmanuel
Macron en 2019 il a changé d'avis depuis
mais c'est toujours la vie de 93% des
actifs de ce pays et déjà en 2019 les
régimes spéciaux étaient érigés en bouc
émissaire alors bien sûr monsieur qu'on
n'aime pas le terme de pénibilité il a
d'ailleurs retiré quatre de ces critères
en 2017 or précisément les régimes
spéciaux répondent aux enjeux de
pénibilité dans les métiers concernés la
philosophie de la sécurité sociale
c'était même d'étendre les dispositifs
dont bénéficie les personnes sous régime
spécial à tous les travailleurs mettre
fin au régime spéciaux sous prétexte
d'équité et de justice n'est qu'une
diversion pour faire oublier l'essentiel
qui est que cette réforme des retraites
va faire 100% de perdants
merci